so I grew up in New York I was born in
the Bronx but I never lived in the Bronx
I always feel like it gave me
credibility to have Bronx blood my
grandparents are all from the Lower East
Side of New York City and then moved to
the Bronx when it was like the country
that's how it was back then the Bronx
was actually the place that you would
move to not from and my parents both
grew up in the Bronx so that's why I was
born there because my mother wanted me
to be born near where her mother lived
so
um and the hospital is still there and
life went on I always
um
had a fascination with hippies I would
always like beg my mother to take me to
go see the hippies and she would take me
to Washington Square Park and they
wouldn't be there and I'd be like where
are they and she would always say um
maybe they don't come out during the day
you know and that was like probably the
worst thing she could ever tell me
because I couldn't wait to be old enough
to find out like what happens at night
so
um I went to school and stuff and I was
in a big big hurry all the time like I
was in a big big hurry to get here
wherever here is and
um
I went to college when I was 16 because
I was in the big rush that I was and
graduated when I was 20 and then I uh I
lived in a couple of different places
along the way I lived in Philly I lived
in DC and I lived in London and whenever
I would leave New York
I often would get myself into trouble
and
um
in New York for some reason
it keeps me more
not out of trouble but it keeps me more
like careful in some ways not that I
didn't dabble in a lot of dangerous
situations and experiment in a lot of
crazy things like growing up but uh New
York is where my home base is and um
somehow on Manhattan Island it keeps me
safer than other places
so in this love story of mine
um
person that I met at that time
uh it was a wild time in the city there
were no cell phones there were no
computers you know you used your
quarters quarters were like so valuable
because you needed them for phone you
needed them for Pac-Man and video games
and you needed them for laundry so you
know it was a time when change mattered
when um I don't even know to this day
how we got everywhere we did though we
met up we got places and we never ever
needed GPS and now I don't know how I
would ever live without GPS but but
somehow these were the days pre-that and
um I was working on 9th Street in
Manhattan in the in the in the East
Village which was very bad then not bad
bad it was really cool actually but like
you wouldn't go past
certain blocks and it was like when when
Tompkins Square had people like really
living in tents and you wouldn't really
go past Avenue B because it was
dangerous now there's million dollar
apartments on Avenue D which is crazy
and my grandparents going back to them
they lived over there back in the days
way before and um it's like this whole
cycle like my grandparents couldn't
understand why I was so wanting to be in
the East Village in the Lower East Side
which is where they got out of and it's
just like I would be like God I wish you
kept your apartment you know but um
anyhow I was working in a vintage
clothing store on 9th Street called
roses and there was a bar right next
door to it called the Aztec the Aztec
was a really cool bar and um
it was just a great spot
um it had those skeletons
that uh if you ever saw the movie
Desperately Seeking Susan in the bag
that Madonna used to carry it had the
skeletons um
my partner would know the artist I
forget everything I retained nothing but
like the artist was a very very
popular artist in the time it had like
those skull scarfs and everything was
skulls skull skulls but there was these
skull things that the Aztec had in in
there I believe and um
and and that we I had a friend I'm not
sure if I'm supposed to say his name or
not but I'll call him JB and he came
into my store it was a it was I know
dates dates are very very important to
me I don't know why I read into
everything but numbers are very big for
me and it was February 9th
and um
that's when it snowed a lot too like I
don't know if technology has anything to
do with snow because there's been no
snow this winter and that winter there
were tons of snow snow like up to here
like winter used to be really winter and
it was February and it was Winter it was
cold and I lived then in on Mulberry
Street which was Little Italy which now
is called NoHo and it's so chic chic
chic when I lived there it was like
Bodega Bodega
Mr Gotti Mr Gotti used to take his
strolls around the block like you knew
when he was on the Block you could smell
his cologne and he was so nice he would
be like hello ladies he was so nice but
that block was so cool then and now I go
there and I feel like one of the little
ladies that used to sit on the sidewalk
and I go like it's like Chic Boutique
Chic Cafe chic chic it's so it's like
Avenue D now so like all these
neighborhoods that were so different
are not like that anymore but back to
9th Street so JB comes into roses where
I worked and uh he says what are you
doing tonight now I used I'm a a
songwriter and I I write a lot but I'm
not like I'm very unorganized type
person I don't like have a book I write
on scrap paper all the time I have so
many pieces of scrap paper with
everything written on it I I just like
journals are difficult for me because
when I was a kid I did start journaling
and then people would read them and um
that happened to me multiple times and
other things happened where my journals
go I don't know so I don't I don't trust
I've trust issues too like I just have
all these issues so anyhow I write on
scraps of paper more than I write in a
formalized book so I remember that day
specifically it's so bizarre because I
was writing that day because I noticed
on my hand I had a ring from one of my
grandmothers I had a bracelet from my
other grandmother and then I had a ring
that I found in the bathroom at the
Aztec on the Aztec floor and I was I was
like what is the significance of the
ring for my grandmother the ring the
bracelet from my grandmother and the
ring that I found on the Aztec bathroom
floor and I wrote all about this and I
was like I'm not it was a Monday night
I was like I'm not going out tonight no
sex no drugs no rock and roll I am going
home and then in walks JB and he says
what are you doing tonight and I'm like
nothing I'm going home and he says oh
come on uh let's go to the Cat Club
which used to be a bar club that's not
here anymore it's actually now a hotel
um and I was just like no no no and he's
like come on I have guest list passes
and and somebody's playing and we can go
and have fun and I was like no I don't
want to go I'm going home and he said
well will you go next door for a drink
to the Aztec and I said no I don't want
to drink tonight and he's like come on
so he twisted my arm and I said fine
I'll go next door
so I closed the store go next door and
everyone then like we all were friends
with the bartender
we all knew everybody kind of I mean I
always feel like I'm not like in the in
In Crowd like I know some people and
then I'm not in like the out I always
feel like I'm in the middle of like
these people and these people so I never
fit in any group because I'm never like
I'm always in the middle of everything I
always see both sides of the track I
always you know I always I was supposed
to be the doctor lawyer of my family and
I just always see both sides it's really
hard for me to
pick one so anyhow we're in the Aztec
and I was wearing a Union Jack t-shirt
underneath this big fur coat okay the
fur coat has a story too I don't know if
I'll get to that but
in walk these two guides
and um
they see my Union Jack shirt and one of
them was British so they said oh are you
British and I'm like no and and
um one of them was American and one was
and they said oh we just came off the
plane from England and
um we're just and then the one who was
American says oh yeah this is my friend
and I'm showing him around town and and
um this friend ends up being somebody
that we just started talking and JB knew
him the bartender knew him and all the
people knew him and we never met until
that minute and we're and it's because
of the Union Jack t-shirt so and they
said that they just got off a plane from
England
not true but they said they did so we're
just talking talking talking talking
talking talking talking
and it was like one of those things like
like we felt like we knew each other but
we never did and and nobody thought we
didn't know each other everyone thought
we knew each other before that day we
had to like prove that we never knew
each other because
we all knew we knew a lot of the same
people in that bar that night but we had
never met so I kept looking at my rings
and my bracelet and thinking my
grandmother my grandmother the Aztec
bathroom hmm
so somehow in that evening I end up in
the Aztec bathroom with this person
and I'm thinking in my mind and
I just thought in my mind like I can't
believe it I never knew what you would
look like I never thought you'd look
like this
but I knew that second that this person
was going to be in my life for a very
long time now I remember always even
saying a very long time I never said
forever because
I don't even know why and very often to
this day I'm always like has it been a
very long time already like it's been
very far in the future now and trust me
it's had a lot of bumps and we're kind
of going through a bump right now very
big bump but this is far into the future
so we we get into the bathroom I have
this thought and then
um
I just knew something was up so then
that night somehow ended I'm not gonna
say where but a few a day or so goes by
and and this is what he tells me that he
called me remember no cell phones
um and and and I said hello and he
always tells me when when he said what's
up that I somehow said oh I was waiting
for you to call now I don't really
remember saying that but I could have
said that and he remembers that I said
that and um and we started seeing each
other and this was remember February
so we started seeing each other and we
were living a little bit recklessly we
definitely partied quite a bit and it
was really fun and it would be like
um crazy experiences and wild nights and
wildlife in New York City after clubs
going to the Avenue B and C places that
you only went to after hours clubs you
would never go there in the day and you
would leave like when stray dogs were
still foaming at the mouths when you'd
get out of there in the morning saying
like oh my God where am I and um somehow
you'd make it back to your place in time
to get to work and that's how it was and
I knew that it couldn't go on like that
and I mean we had times where he'd be
banging on my door let me and I'd be
like no no and and then I would and it
it got really very it was very very
um emotional and very passionate
and then we somehow said
like we will do or die do we want to die
together or do we want to live together
and and we both knew that the the
wildness had to end if we wanted to live
together and and have a future and then
he started saying to me
um I have to go away maybe on business I
I might have to go away to Texas for for
a few years and I'd be like Texas like
well I'll come with you I mean what did
I care I worked in a vintage clothing
store I wasn't like a career and um and
he would just like like drop these
little clues that somehow something
might happen where I might have to go
away and
um I
believed whatever he said whatever so
like
um
so then like one day I get a phone call
from his job saying
uh somebody got arrested and he's in um
Center Street which is where they take
you and I'm just like what oh my God and
I wrote on this pink piece of paper this
little me in my scrap paper I wrote oh
my God I will I will do whatever it
takes I I will be with you forever I
will marry you I'm going to stand by you
and I wrote thinking I could give him
this note and I ran down to Center
Street because supposedly he was going
to get arraigned or something and I I
went into the
to the courtrooms
and I couldn't find this pink piece of
paper but I didn't know that yet and I
think I saw him I don't remember but
when I saw him I didn't have the paper
and it was freaking me out I don't
remember exactly I went home because I
didn't live that far from there and then
I maybe that's when I realized I didn't
have the paper but I went back to there
and you know those doors that go like
this I I went retracing my footsteps and
in this freaking door believe it or not
in one of these doors like go like this
I saw that pink piece of paper on the
floor and in my headphones I always like
had a Walkman and I would always listen
to the radio for some reason because
not always but often I love Radio and on
my headphones as I'm picking up this
paper that song by Diana Ross and Mr
Prince
someday we'll be together within my
headphones and this is a moment I will
never forget and I find the piece of
paper and I'm like oh my God and that's
going in my ears and it was just this
moment of I I couldn't believe it so
then somehow
he goes to Rikers Island
so I went visiting him at Rikers Island
and
um I would have to hide my Walkman
outside the gates of uh there was like a
little dirt patch in a tree I would hide
my Walkman there because you couldn't
bring it in and um and I'd visit him
and then um he told me what happened
because I had no freaking clue as to
what was going on and he said that he
had been arrested for this silly little
thing for stealing twenty dollars out of
the pocket of some guy one night he was
hanging out with friends they were
drinking screwdrivers they ran out of
orange juice he had to go to the deli to
pick it up and when he went to the deli
there were these two like girls with
this guy and they were chatting him up
and he um went to the store to get the
orange juice and when he went into his
pocket he had twenty dollars it wasn't
there
so his twenty dollars was gone so he
came out and the girls were gone and the
guy was still there and he was like I
want my twenty dollars I want my twenty
dollars and the guy's like I didn't know
those girls I didn't do anything and he
said I want my twenty dollars and the
guy gave him twenty dollars he goes into
the store when he comes out of the store
there were police there that arrested
him for stealing the twenty dollars from
this guy who ended up being a D.A and he
was with these girls
so that was the story I got
anyway he said he was arrested he got
um two years he was out on bail he
jumped bail he was at work every single
day he knew they would find him but he
didn't want to go back and eventually
they found him at his job and because he
did that he had two years to do that's
all I heard that's all I knew and it was
like okay so they took him and he went
from there then he went to another place
which was Beacon I believe New York
which is like another down state it's
called and then from there he went all
over New York State I got the New York
State Prison tour uh I heard of this was
in April okay we met in February April
just happened so we knew each other from
February to April he goes away and then
I start visiting him and then I start
hearing of a thing called Trailer visits
that if you're married you get to have a
trailer visit and I really wanted to see
what a trailer was like so I said let's
get married or he did and I I was like
really curious to see what a trailer was
like so you get these conjugal visits
and um and he got moved to after like uh
that place he went to a place all the
way up in the Adirondacks in Lake Placid
New York
and uh
we started planning a wedding and I met
this girl I would take a bus it was
probably like eight hours or something
ridiculous thing there was a bus company
called prison Gap
and they would take buses to take you up
to these prisons and visit for your
seven hours or whatever it was and then
they'd take you on the bus back and um
I started taking these buses and and I
met this girl and we were like I would
we were like Lucy and Ricky and she and
her person were like Fred Nestle and I
felt like that's who we were and um I'm
still friends with her to this day uh
she's no longer that person has passed
away and um
and she and I I get all the wedding
stuff together and we got married in
June uh so we met February
he went away in April we get married in
June okay
cool cool so
um anyhow we get married June 27th
another while he's in prison yeah and um
it the the person who married us we I
rented a car to go up there it was
pouring rain like like one of the worst
rains you've ever seen like you can't
see in front of you and my friend was
like rain is good luck rain is good luck
and we're driving we were like oh my God
it was crazy we stay at this little
Motel I I had a dress that I dyed silver
to wear at the wedding
um I it was a silver dress and and the
because I figured you know jail silver
prison bars I don't know I just made it
silver for some reason I'm thinking now
is that why I did it I don't even know I
made it silver but maybe it was and um
and we get there and it was a Justice of
the Peace who married us and it was his
he was retiring on July 1st so this was
the last wedding he was ever going to
have and on his desk it even said
something like uh
oh God what did his paper he had a paper
on his desk saying like
like this is it or something I don't
remember but I used to remember but I
don't anymore I might have it somewhere
and uh he it was the last wedding he was
ever going to do so we get married and
then me and my friend that night for my
honeymoon there was one little movie
theater in this teeny little town in in
Lake Placid and we went to the movies
and I saw Witches of Eastwick that night
for my honeymoon with her and uh and
then we start planning for a trailer
visit
okay as soon as we would get the
paperwork everything set for getting a
trailer visit he would get transferred
to another place
so he would get to another place and
then I'd start visiting him there and
then we would try to get a trailer visit
and as soon as we would get this close
to the trailer was that he would get
transferred to another prison I went all
over this freaking State like you've
never believed I I never even knew these
towns and I've seen a lot of them and he
would get transferred he even then got
they thought because I visited him all
the time that I was bringing drugs and
he would get searched and I would get
searched and and then he got sent to
dannemora like maximum security all the
way up in God knows where New York and
um and sometimes I would go in and stay
for like a week because I would make
friends with some other woman who like
ends up like getting an apartment
because she couldn't be too far away
from her person and uh I'd end up
staying with her I was at a place called
Elmira for a week and there was the Mark
Twain Motel which I used to stay at and
I would like walk from the motel to the
prison and um and years later I ended up
playing in Elmira and I stayed at the
Mark Twain Hotel and it was just like I
have a song about that called unfinished
business and and it's just like
like life is just crazy so during all
this time my family had no idea in the
world that I got married zero my parents
were actually like on a trip to Italy
when uh when I got married so they
weren't even in the country they had no
idea now I worked for this company I'm
I'm not sure if I'm allowed to say it
but like I have all these jobs I worked
for a courier company
one of those like you know delivery
things and uh my dad knew somebody that
knew somebody there and he couldn't
understand how they my name was not
listed and he never told me this but he
he he told me after the truth came out
because
story plot thickens
the following
February so one year after we met
and one like me visiting him now for all
these months my brother
had got diagnosed with AIDS
so that kind of took
a big part of the family turn my brother
now being ill and this is now February
and then April you see is taxes and my
dad always used an accountant that did
our taxes and I was not giving him my
tax information and he kept bugging me
like like we'd be in the hospital
visiting my brother and he'd be like
where's your tax stuff where's your tax
stuff and I was like delaying it like
why didn't I say I'll do my own taxes I
didn't even think that and I just kept
delaying giving him my tax stuff and
finally in the hospital one day I said
dad I have to tell you something
my name is different I have a different
name now I changed my name I changed
everything and he was just like no
wonder why so-and-so couldn't find you
at that place and I was like yeah he
said I was looking and they couldn't
understand why so anyway
he found out that I got married they
were very upset then they find out that
he's in prison
and my brother then starts going in and
out of the hospital for almost two years
it's like always two years so uh one
time over that summer when my brother
was out of the hospital we all went on a
road trip to Elmira family they wanted
to go see him and visit
so my brother and my parents and I all
go to visit him in Elmira and uh they
they did that
and um I guess they kind of welcomed him
into the family I'm not so sure but when
the whole thing was over uh April of two
years later after prison after prison we
never got a trailer visit not one
um he comes home and then my parents
want a real wedding they want us to have
a wedding for their friends and family
and to make it like legit so now that my
brother's sick he became best man at
this wedding so it was really a party
for him as well so June 24th two years
later we had a second wedding where my
brother was best man and still guys no
really no cell phones no selfies no
taking pictures of everything so we
don't have a lot of footage we have
photographs but we don't have a lot of
video we don't have a lot of like all
those other kinds of pictures that you
have but we have memories and um we had
the wedding it was awkward people didn't
understand why I wasn't nervous but I
was already married for two years and um
I had a dress I was supposed to get
married once before and it never
happened and uh I had a dress from this
wedding that never happened and I ended
up just using that dress and
um
and we had this wedding and my brother
was sick and we never went on a
honeymoon and we've never did anything
because of the focus of Life at that
time was my brother so this was June my
brother lasted he's my producer from up
above until the following December we
got married in June he passed away
December 8th
so it was really all about him and
um one month later I got pregnant
something I thought I was never able to
do I was like pretty much the only girl
I ever knew that didn't have an abortion
I thought I couldn't get pregnant and uh
I had a dream about my brother and
served soon after that
um I was pregnant with our first child
and
I got chills saying that we have two
incredible daughters that
for whatever reasons we're together it
was definitely to make these two
children they are just amazing this is
their little sister this is the baby now
and um our girls
if there was any way to describe the
most incredible humans and trust me they
went through their bumps and stuff too
but they're older now and they are in
incredible relationships with their
partners and it's just the biggest
blessing in the whole wide world that
these two girls exist in this world and
for whatever reason I'm telling you that
is the reason I believe we're together
is because of these two children
he and I have had
many ups and downs but there's something
about us we have like a loyalty Gene
um
our our relationship for some reason
like I said earlier is in a very s very
very sensitive spot right now
but somehow he showed up today to be
here and um
we're like
we're like parallel people like there's
something very bizarre I soon found out
years later my grandfather passed away
and I didn't even know this but February
9th the day we met
uh was their wedding anniversary my
grandparents remember my grandmother's
bracelet I was wearing
and my other grandmother I have chills
right now
um
her name was Evelyn
his mother's name is Evelyn
uh my grandfather's name is Arthur his
name is Arthur so I I always thought
like Arthur and Evelyn those two
Grandparents were the ones behind it all
because his name's Arthur his mother's
Evelyn but then when I found out
February 9th is my other grandparents
wedding anniversary it's like
that like explained the the ring from my
grandmother and the bracelet from my
other grandmother and we all know about
the ring from the Aztec bathroom that
was the one that really made it all come
together and that's pretty much like
a lot of the story with a lot left out
it's beautiful thank you so much